when the parents disappear he only
leaves us a few old photos
[Music
] growing up knowing
i imagined my parents together at the
time when they loved each other so i
opened my mother's suitcase the suitcase
of secrets i only had left
only to revive them
[Applause]
sony music with my brother it's not
possible died in the camps he's
coming from moscow I think dead
if I think exactly
it's sure that it's your brother you think
that she's a mole you
do you think about communist bukhara and
resigning she's beautiful the tears
the first time i saw i knew she
was the woman of my life and she
thought that soon  the man of her life when you
do everything he says but you do
n't do everything he says
ah ah
elie you don't know him either than
he walked deserter spy
what's the truth  that's why it's
burgundy by other than guys like
you on goal at stakes not lying that
I admire and d  the nonsense we
regret not having done
is your brother that to my brother
a woman
that we would have met in our lives and
that we would have loved simply for those
they were
[Music]